If you want to become a master painter, you do not just trace over a master's brushstrokes.
Tracing might yield A flawless copy of a masterpiece.
You might match the curves, the shading, the exact geometric proportions of the original.
But tracing does not make you an artist.
It makes you a human stencil.
I see the distinction.
You are producing the gesture without possessing the vision that birthed the gesture.
Today we are exploring a historical argument
that a vast number of people make this exact mistake with their spiritual lives.
Welcome.
I am so glad you are here with us for this deep dive.
Settle in, clear your mind, and make yourself comfortable.
We are stepping into a very deliberate, unhurried space today.
We are opening Reza Shah Kazemi's book, Spiritual Ethos, to look at a text that asks us to reconsider the very architecture of spiritual life by focusing on a single monumental figure.
The thesis we are going to explore is profound.
and it must be stated exactly as the text presents it.
Ali is the Prophet's own soul, the gate through which the Quran and the prophetic nature became a living human path.
Our mission for this exploration is to fundamentally redefine what it truly means to follow a spiritual exemplar.
In our modern discourse, the concept of following has been, well, it has been flattened into something procedural and superficial.
It has.
We are going to explore the idea that following the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, does not mean merely copying his outward acts.
It means inwardly assimilating his very substance.
To understand what that assimilation actually looks like, we have to start by setting a historical stage.
We need to go back to a very specific room at a very specific moment in time.
The crisis begins at a clan feast.
Picture the gathering.
It is a feast of the Hashimite clan in Mecca.
In this room sit the grown, proud leaders of the tribal structure.
The heavyweights of the society.
Precisely those men.
These are men of immense social standing, deeply steeped in the heavy responsibilities, the economic realities, and the fierce politics of their time.
They have been summoned by the Prophet.
He stands before them and asks a question that will quite literally alter the course of human history.
Let me set up the sheer gravity of this.
Please do.
He looks at these seasoned leaders and asks, who among you will help me in this mission?
Who will be my brother, my executor, and my successor?
We must examine the anatomy of what happens next.
The Prophet asks this monumental question and the response from the most powerful men in the room is a heavy, suffocating silence.
A profound, paralyzing silence.
These seasoned men meet this question by doing absolutely nothing.
They're calculating.
We must understand the geopolitical reality of Mecca at that moment.
The stakes were unimaginably high.
They were.
Mecca's entire economy and social hierarchy are built upon the idol worship at the sanctuary.
The prophet's message of absolute monotheism threatens to shatter that economic lifeblood.
It threatens to overturn the entire social order.
So to align with this message is to invite absolute ruin.
To stand up in that room is to volunteer
exile, economic devastation, and likely war.
So they weigh the costs, they hesitate.
Think about the last time you were in a room where speaking the truth carried a massive social cost.
That paralyzing silence is human nature operating at its most basic self-preserving level.
But against the backdrop of that total silence, one voice speaks up.
One single voice.
It is the voice.
Of a boy, perhaps 13 or 14 years old.
He stands up alone to answer.
This boy is Ali, peace be upon him.
A young teenager surrounded by the most powerful men in his world, and he is the singular individual who does not pause to calculate the cost.
That instinct to answer when grown men hesitated, that immediate unflinching readiness, it forms the miniature shape of his entire life.
It becomes his signature.
It is the signature of his character.
And to speak of Ali, to study this singular flakr of earliest Islam is to speak of the quintessential spirituality of the Islamic tradition itself.
The entire edifice of Islamic
spirituality flows from 2 fundamental sources, the revelation of the Quran and the inspired example of the prophet.
How is this different from ordinary imitation?
When we talk about following an example, we usually mean someone we watch and try to mimic.
We catalog their actions and try to reproduce them in our own lives.
That is the core crisis we have to navigate here.
When the perdition speaks of the prophet's Sunnah, his living example, modern reductionism views it exactly as you just described, as a set of gestures to be codified, cataloged, and copied.
Like checking boxes on a rubric.
Just like that.
But we must draw our attention to a specific verse in the Quran which addresses the prophet directly, stating, Verily, thou art of a tremendous nature.
That is chapter 68, verse 4.
A tremendous nature.
That tremendous nature is the spiritual substance of prophetic perfection.
The words and deeds of the prophet are merely the outward expressions of that inward substance.
They do not exhaust it.
Following in this spiritual context is not mimicking gestures.
It is the arduous, transformative process of assimilating that inward, tremendous nature into your own being.
So we are talking about a failed reading of what it means to be a follower, the immense temptation of outward imitation.
It is a profound and incredibly common pitfall.
A person might copy the outward forms of the prophet's conduct with flawless exactitude.
Down to the smallest detail.
They might perfect the physical gestures of prayer, the daily routines of eating and sleeping, the precise speech patterns.
They might look entirely orthodox, yet spiritually they could remain entirely on the outside.
Like the tracing we discussed earlier.
They are tracing the lines of the masterpiece.
They are imitating the gesture without possessing the internal reality, the spiritual state that birthed the gesture.
I don't buy that yet because we live in an era that fundamentally believes in the power of habituation.
Modern psychology preaches fake it till you make it.
The concept of neuroplasticity suggests that outward, repetitive physical actions actually rewire your internal chemistry over time.
I hear that argument often.
If a person flawlessly replicates a perfect outward action over and over, if they pray with the exact physical movements, if they give to charity exactly as instructed, if they police their speech meticulously,
Wouldn't that intense physical discipline eventually cultivate a perfect internal state of being organically?
Why wouldn't the outside eventually shape the inside?
The temptation of the modern procedural mind is to want a mechanism.
We want a guarantee that if we input the correct physical data, the machine will output spiritual perfection.
But spiritual reality operates on an entirely different physics.
Different physics entirely.
The outward shaping the inside is habituation, yes.
You can habituate a person to be polite, you can habituate a person to be calm, but you cannot habituate a person into possessing A tremendous nature.
Genuine spiritual right action must flow organically from within rather than being synthetically imposed from without.
Okay, I am starting to see the gap there.
Think of the difference between a puppet whose limbs are moved perfectly by external strings
living creature whose movements are the natural expression of its own internal life force.
There is a profound categorical difference between a follower who merely trails behind an example perpetually striving to match a stencil and a follower who has been inwardly remade by it.
So one is being pulled and the other is moving under its own power.
Ali represents the second kind.
The prophetic substance genuinely took up residence within him.
He did not just study the example.
He became an extension of the reality behind it.
Because he possessed the life force itself.
To contextualize the mechanics of how this is even possible, we must look at another Quranic verse, chapter 33, verse 6.
It states, the prophet is closer to the believers than they are to themselves.
This is a staggering ontological claim.
Closer to the believers than they are to themselves.
Well, it reveals A mysterious affinity that transcends time, physical space, and biological lineage.
Let us linger on that.
How can another being be closer to me than my own self?
My own self is the very center of my perception.
I mean, there's nothing closer to me than my own ego.
It forces us to ask what the self actually is.
If your self is just your ego, your calculated desires, the part of you that hesitates at a clan feast, then yes, you are the center of that.
But the tradition teaches that beneath the ego is the primordial soul, the divine breath.
The deepest core.
The prophetic light is the origin of that purity.
Therefore, the awakened soul intuits the prophetic essence not as something foreign to be studied from afar, but as the deepest, truest core of its own identity.
It's a closeness of essence.
If the Prophet is closer to every awakened believer than they are to themselves, we have to look closely at the language the Prophet used when speaking specifically about Ali.
There are three key sayings we need to walk through that build this interiorization thesis.
The 3 sayings form progression.
The first is a saying where the Prophet declares that Ali is as my own soul.
We must weigh that phrase very slowly.
On the surface, an historian or a cynic could read it merely as a statement of deep familial affection.
There were cousins.
They lived in one household.
The prophet was the older figure who raised him.
It sounds like a father speaking of a son.
It does, but this.
reaches far past biographical affection.
By affirming that Ali is as my own soul, the Prophet is affirming an ultimate realized identity between the sanctified human soul and the prophetic nature.
It is bridging the human and the prophetic.
It is a highly particular bond between two specific historical individuals, yes, but it serves to reveal a universal spiritual principle about what the human soul is capable of becoming when it is fully turned toward its source.
The second saying pushes this even further into the realm of the extraordinary.
The prophet said, you are from me and I am from you.
The second-half of that is the key.
Okay, let's unpack this, because the first half makes complete sense.
A pupil being from a teacher or a younger man raised by a master being from that master fits all standard hierarchies of influence.
But the prophet saying, and I am from you, completely defies that hierarchy.
It entirely subverts the standard flow of authority.
For the prophet to say, and I am from you, points to something much deeper than a lineage of influence.
It points to a profound mutual indwelling.
Mutual indwelling.
It implies that what the prophet carried and what Ali carried were not two separate substances operating in tandem.
They were one shared reality expressed through two distinct persons.
The Prophet is acknowledging a communion that cannot be reduced to a mere teacher and student dynamic.
Consider our first governing analogy here, the mirror.
Explain the mechanics of the mirror in this context.
Think of ancient metallurgy, where a mirror was not made of glass, but of metal that had to be painstakingly polished of all rust and oxidation.
The rust represents the ego, the individual desires, the calculations that cloud human perception.
The calculations we saw from the men at the feast.
Ali's readiness at 13 years old shows a mirror entirely devoid of rust.
Because his soul was perfectly polished of any obscuring ego, he could perfectly reflect the Prophet's own substance.
He receives it without altering it.
He receives the light wholly while adding absolutely nothing of his own distortion to it.
The reflection is so perfect, so pristine, that the source, the prophet, sees his own essence entirely within the reflection.
Hence, I am from you.
The light recognizes itself in the flawless mirror.
That brings us to the third saying, which shifts the focus slightly from the purse of the prophet to the revelation itself.
The prophet said, Ali is with the Quran and the Quran is with Ali.
They will not separate from each other until they return to me at the paradisal pool.
This is a monumental declaration.
That sounds like wordplay.
It is one thing to perfectly reflect a human being, even a perfect human being, but what does it actually mean for a human being to be with a text until the end of time?
Books are ink and paper.
people are flesh and blood.
You can study a text, you can memorize a text, but how can you mutually indwell with a book?
It demands that we stop viewing the Revelation as an inert physical object, mere ink and paper.
We must understand it as a living, breathing spiritual force.
This third saying is the ultimate statement of absolute interiorization.
Interiorization of the text itself.
Ali did not just memorize the vocabulary of the text.
He did not merely study its legal rulings or historical narratives.
He became the book's inseparable companion by making its inner reality the very substance of his own soul.
He lives within its meaning and its meaning lives within him.
He became the walking embodiment of it.
He became the walking, breathing embodiment of the divine word.
When we synthesize these three sayings, we see that the twin pillars of Islamic spirituality, the Quran and the Prophet, were not left as external objects of study.
They were fully absorbed into a living human being.
We've been talking entirely about the inward reality so far.
The inner assimilation, the mutual indwelling, the polishing of the mirror of the soul.
But a soul cannot contain an ocean without it breaching the banks.
It has to spill over.
If a soul fully interiorizes these twin sources to that absolute degree, what happens outwardly?
What is the tangible historical manifestation of that inward state?
The manifestation is a sheer staggering overflow of wisdom.
We must look at how the Quran, specifically chapter 2, verse 269, defines wisdom.
It calls it an abundant good granted by God.
An abundant good.
True wisdom is never something a soul manufactures on its own through cleverness.
It is always a gift, a descent of reality into the human vessel.
The vast, unassailable body of teachings, sermons, theological discourses, and complex judgments attributed to Ali is not just the product of an unusually productive or brilliant mind at work.
It's not just heavy intellectual output.
It is the visible trace of an invisible fullness spilling over.
When A vessel is filled to the absolute brim with that abundant good, it must pour out into the world.
And that pouring out became the headwaters for almost everything that followed in the civilization.
Precisely.
This is where the spiritual reality reshapes history.
Later authorities trace nearly
every single Islamic science back to him as the foundational source.
That is a massive claim.
We are talking about the strict logic of jurisprudence, the lofty abstractions of theology, the deep layers of Koranic exegesis.
the structural foundations of Arabic grammar, the aesthetic majesty of calligraphy, and the profound mystical knowledge associated with Sufism.
All of those distinct disciplines.
Historians might engage in endless debates regarding the precise foundational role he played in the microscopic minutia of each separate field, but the tradition's own collective memory places him unequivocally at the origin point.
He is the intellectual and spiritual impulse from which these disciplines sprang.
There's a quote from the poet Nasiri Khusra,
that captures the sheer scale of this phenomenon.
He wrote, if your tree bears the fruit of knowledge, you will bring the turning heavens beneath your sway.
It is an incredibly audacious image, bringing the turning heavens beneath your sway.
But it serves to clarify that knowledge in this ancient spiritual context is not an inert store of facts.
It is not just trivia or data.
It is a living, penetrating, operative force that reshapes the cosmos.
The tradition does not feel it is exaggerating when it traces an entire civilization's complex sciences back to one man because it understands the nature of the knowledge he carried.
It was not human speculation, it was the interiorized revelation breaking outward.
Which establishes the pivot of our entire discussion, the ultimate framework for understanding his role.
The prophet declared,
I am the city of knowledge and Ali is its gate.
So whoever desires knowledge, let him enter by the gate.
This brings us to our second governing analogy, the gate to the city of knowledge.
We must examine what a gate actually does.
A city without a gate is just a walled fortress impenetrable, closed off, withholding its riches from the thirsty world outside.
It traps everything inside.
A gate is the mechanism of access.
It regulates the profound wealth inside the city and translates it to the outside.
Ali is the single doorway through which the immensity of prophetic wisdom becomes accessible to the rest of humanity.
He is the threshold.
He did not invent these diverse disciplines out of thin air.
Rather, he embodied the living source from which they could be drawn.
The city is the absolute fullness of the prophetic wisdom, and he is the threshold.
Because of him, the pure, unapproachable light of revelation became human, transmissible, and alive.
Ali is the prophet's own soul, the gate through which the Qur'an and the prophetic nature became a living human path.
To understand how a single human being could possibly bear the weight of being that gate without shattering under the pressure of that abundant good, we have to meticulously examine the biographical roots of his sanctity.
The vessel was prepared.
The preparation of this vessel began before he could even speak.
Let us trace those biographical roots.
And it begins with a profound spatial reality.
He had the singular distinction of being born inside the Kaaba in Mecca.
His mother entered the sanctuary and he was born within its walls.
We must pause on the immense metaphysical weight of that specific location.
The Kaaba in pre-Islamic Arabia and certainly within the Islamic worldview is not merely an important stone building.
It is the center.
It is the spiritual axis
of the world.
It is the physical point around which the entire spiritual cosmos revolves.
To be born inside the Kaaba is to have your physical entry into existence perfectly align with the absolute spiritual center of gravity.
It foreshadows a life that will never at any moment deviate from the center.
The alignment continues in his upbringing.
His father was the prophet's uncle.
The same man who had taken in and raised the orphan prophet years earlier.
The destinies of these two figures were deeply woven together from the start.
During a time of severe economic hardship and drought in Mecca, the prophet took Ali, who was only about five years old at the time, into his own household to ease his uncle's financial burden.
So he is brought directly into the physical proximity of the prophet.
We must look at the psychological and spiritual impact of this.
From his most formative, tender years, the child lived physically enveloped
in the prophet's shadow.
He breathed the air of revelation from childhood.
He was present during the prophet's intense spiritual retreats at the mountain of Hera.
He was a witness to the very beginnings of the mission.
He was not learning about the prophetic nature from a distance.
He was assimilating the very sensory environment of revelation.
He later recounted that he could smell the fragrance of prophecy before the mission was ever publicly declared to the world.
So it is no surprise that he was the very first male to embrace the faith, stepping forward without hesitation at just 9 or 10 years old.
And that unwavering readiness, that refusal to calculate the cost to himself, continued into young adulthood.
When the enemies in Mecca finally plotted to assassinate the Prophet in his bed, it was a young Ali who volunteered to sleep in that bed.
He wrapped himself in the prophet's mantle, laying his own physical form across the path of the assassins to ensure the prophet could safely make the migration to Medina.
This is the ultimate offering of the self.
He is literally placing his flesh and blood in the space meant for the prophet.
It is the physical manifestation of the phrase as my own soul.
He becomes the literal shield.
But in Medina, we see another vital facet of this extraordinary life emerge.
The spiritual vessel becomes the invincible warrior.
He stood at the absolute forefront of the fierce battles fought to defend the fragile early community.
He never lost a duel.
Never.
At the defining battle of Khaibar, the community faced a massive impregnable fortress.
The Prophet called for him.
Ali was suffering from a severe affliction of the eyes, and the Prophet healed him by touching his eyes.
In the intense heat of that battle, having lost his conventional shield, he approached the fortress, wrenched a heavy iron gate entirely from its hinges, and wielded it as a shield.
The physical gate of a fortress, wrenched free and wielded by the spiritual gate of knowledge.
It is almost too poetically perfect to be mere history.
He wields the physical gate of a seemingly impenetrable fortress to protect the community.
But look at the underlying mechanism of that strength.
The mechanics of the warrior.
The tradition does not view this as merely the adrenaline of a strong warrior.
It is viewed as the physical manifestation of an inward reality.
Because he had become the spiritual gate to the impenetrable city of prophetic knowledge, physical gates yielded to his hands.
The material world inevitably bends to the reality of the spiritual world.
And beyond the fierce arena of the battlefield, his absolute nearness to the prophet was cemented in the most intimate way possible, his marriage to the prophet's daughter.
The confluence of the two lights.
The tradition speaks of her in the highest, most reverent terms, together with their two grandsons,
They formed the core of the people of the house.
This brings us to a crucial theological mechanic.
This household was singled out by the Quran itself, specifically in chapter 33, verse 33, which declares that God wished to remove all impurity from them and purify them completely.
Complete purification.
What does complete purification mean?
It means the total eradication of the rust on the mirror.
It means the absolute removal of any egoic obstruction that could prevent the perfect transmission of the prophetic light.
They are the purified vessels through which the grace of the tradition flows forward into history.
Let us look at how the broader traditions synthesized all of this.
Here's where it gets really interesting.
Because the testimonies to his extraordinary standing
merits, are not confined to 1 sect, one historical faction, or one group of partisans.
They are universal.
They are recorded and preserved across all schools, deeply embedded within the most authoritative Sunni collections as well as Shia sources.
The sheer volume, the undeniable weight of these prophetic testimonies is staggering.
The Prophet declared that merely gazing upon Ali is an act of worship.
Let that sink in.
Gazing is worship.
Looking at a human being is elevated to the status of prayer.
The Prophet prayed that the truth would revolve around him wherever he turned, meaning Ali does not seek the truth.
The truth seeks his alignment.
He becomes the axis.
He stated that loving him is a strict measure of a true believer's soundness of soul, while hating him is the definitive mark of a hypocrite.
And Ali himself articulated A profound arithmetic regarding the knowledge he guarded.
He noted that worldly wealth shrinks when it is spent, but spiritual knowledge multiplies when it is poured out.
The more the gate opens, the more abundant the city becomes.
All of this immense spiritual momentum culminates in a specific historical event at a pool between Mecca and Medina, returning from the final pilgrimage.
The event at Gadir come.
A defining moment.
The Prophet had a pulpit raised out of saddles, gathered the 10s of thousands of pilgrims in the searing heat, and made a monumental declaration.
For whomever I am the mala, Ali is his mala.
We must carefully gloss the word mala here because it carries immense linguistic and spiritual weight.
It means guardian, it means master, but it also
also means intimate friend, the closest ally.
It holds authority in love.
It is a word that holds both supreme authority and profound love simultaneously.
Now, historically, there are two distinct readings of this event at Gadirkum, and it is crucial that we examine both impartially without taking a side to understand the full scope of what was happening.
Lay out the two readings.
The political reading views this public declaration as an unambiguous, explicit designation of immediate political succession.
It sees the prophet as appointing the ruler of the state who must govern after his passing.
And the other side.
The spiritual reading, on the other hand, views it as a profound, undeniable marker
special closeness and supreme spiritual authority, elevating him above all others in proximity to the prophet, but without necessarily amounting to a political nomination for immediate worldly rulership.
But regardless of the historical debates over statecraft and succession, both readings have to fundamentally contend with the reality of what he actually carried within himself.
Indeed.
And this requires our third governing analogy, light upon light on glass and stone.
Walk us through that imagery.
If you take a pure, brilliant light and you shine it through a perfect, pristine piece of glass, the illumination passes through the medium perfectly.
It illuminates everything around it, completely unchanged in its original essence.
The prophetic light was carried by him without dimming, without distortion, without the medium of the glass altering the color of the flame.
The intense political polemics over the centuries, the endless debates over who should have ruled the empire when, they often distract us from what is actually entirely undisputed by both of those historical readings.
If we connect this to the bigger picture, that is the crucial unifying insight of this text.
What is completely undisputed across the entire spectrum of the tradition is his supreme spiritual authority.
The politics may be debated, but the spirituality is not.
The politics of empire may be debated, but the empire of the soul is clear.
This undisputed authority is encapsulated in the vital concept of spiritual guardianship, or walaya.
This concept carries 2 joined meanings that operate together and cannot be separated.
What are those two meanings?
It is the loving fidelity and absolute devotion of the believer on one side.
meeting the spiritual sanctity, authority, and grace of the guide on the other.
It is the magnetic pull between the awakened soul and the perfect mirror of prophecy.
This devotion, this recognition of spiritual guardianship, was not some later invention formalized centuries down the line.
It was prototyped by the early partisans in the prophet's own day figures like Salman, Abidar, Amar, and Mikad.
They saw the light shining through the glass perfectly.
And we must emphasize a central thesis here with absolute clarity.
This devotion, the spiritual guardianship, is not the private sequestered possession of 1 faction.
It is not just a badge for one group.
It is a universal spirituality that belongs to the whole of the Islamic tradition.
He is recognized as the first spiritual pole after the prophet in nearly all mystical chains.
The Sufi orders, across all geographic and political boundaries, trace their lineage, their very spiritual lifeblood, back through him.
The gate must be passed through.
Without the gate, there is no access to the city of mysticism.
The great poet Rumi captured this universal recognition beautifully, writing, learn to act with pure sincerity from Ali, know that the line of God was cleansed of all deceit.
Cleansed of all the rust on the mirror.
So what does this all mean?
We arrive at the stakes of this exploration.
For you, the listener, navigating the complexities of your own inner landscape, what does this demand of your own spiritual following?
If following is not merely copying gestures, what is it?
Demands an internal revolution.
Taking him as a master in this universal sense is not about adopting A political doctrine or nursing A historical grievance.
It is about a profound, often painful emptying of the self.
Emptying the vessel.
It asks you to look inward and clear away your own deceits, your own ego, your own endless calculations.
Just as the grown men at the feast calculated their social standing so that something truer, something of a tremendous nature can take residence within you.
It is a rigorous call to assimilate truth, not just to applaud its historical existence from a safe distance.
We have constructed a vast and intricate portrait today.
We have looked at the 13-year-old boy who answered the suffocating silence when grown men hesitated to risk their worldly standing.
The unmatched warrior who wielded the physical door of a fortress.
The purified husband of the prophetic household.
The living gate of knowledge whose wisdom only multiplied as it was poured out to the world.
Ali is the prophet's own soul.
the gate through which the Quran and the prophetic nature became a living human path.
This raises an important question, one final lingering mystery that we must leave you to carry forward on your own.
We have spent this time establishing exactly what he assimilated, the twin sources of the revelation and the prophetic nature.
But how did he know it?
The actual mechanism of knowing.
By what inner faculty does a human soul actually absorb the living spirit of revelation?
The tradition calls this faculty the intellect, but it is not the intellect.
as we use the word today.
It is not a cold tool for modern calculation, logic, or debate club argument.
It is something much older.
It is an ancient, luminous spiritual organ that sees the real before it ever attempts to reason about it.
The question you must ponder now as you step back into your day is how might you begin to recover this older, deeper, luminous way of knowing within yourself?